not
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody what is up donation
futurist
and dare i say doers today we're going
to be focusing on
web design and product design you guys
this is really
really super cool and more specifically
we're going to talk about how to create
powerful memorable web experiences in
that delight we're going to be looking
at a case study of
master class and actually even get a
live
sketch ae demo today's guest
has background in ui and ux and
interesting enough motion design as well
he's a senior product designer fantasy
he's worked at punch cut
and runs his own independent design
studio called phil graph
and he studied mobile design at hyper
island here's some of his really cool
super exciting sexy work it's pretty
nice jonah
pretty smooth this guy yeah and we we've
had a lot of requests for web work
web design and ui and ux and so i'm
thrilled to welcome
pontus belgraf he's based out of sweden
but currently working in san francisco
you guys just follow him everywhere on
social media
well graph and check out his website
willgraph.com
pontus welcome to the show yeah thank
you
yay all right we made it okay here we go
yeah we made it baby we made it now
you're in san francisco in your
your design studio and uh thankfully we
do we were just
uh chatting before we went live and
things are getting a little bit better
with the air quality right
yeah it's much better uh it was a very
apocalyptic
moment there for two it did feel like it
those orange skies
straight out of blade runner 2049.
excellent we have a jam-packed episode
today
and you've prepared a lot of stuff yeah
so i'm going to turn this show over to
you now
and take it away maestro okay thanks so
much
so first off thank you everyone for
tuning in
chris the future team super excited i've
been pumped for this for so many weeks
now and finally we're here
and i have so many things to share and
hopefully i don't do it
as fast uh so you can follow through but
let me know in any chats or
conversations
along the way but before we go into the
actual things
uh let me give you little intro where i
come from
so my name is pontius valgroff a product
designer and
electronic dance music enthusiast from
sweden
this is me raving with my flag in ultra
miami
a few years ago and yeah a pretty
energetic i would call them
yes you are would you do this i'm tired
just watching you here
wow yeah those guys in the background is
drinking beer
okay and then i i was founded in a small
town in sweden so as you can see
out in the countryside small village uh
spent a portion of my life there
before i went into school used a town
close by
i went i.t but didn't really felt like
that was my thing
so i started to do designs on the side
i found photoshop my dad always
encouraged me to open photoshop instead
of paint but i
was always saying no but then eventually
i found cs203
i believe and then you're starting to
play around with different images
took stock photos i think i even stole
this
shutterstock account for my job at the
time to get these high quality images
we won't tell anybody hopefully they're
not on this screen right now no they're
not
sure they're not they're just combining
images as you can see using fun
uh different compositions and styles
just finding
what i like and after this i think i
lost access to this account and i
realized it's hard to
get good quality without getting stocks
and it was super expensive so i moved
over to
trying to build my portfolio and the way
i got traction
from the beginning was to create
resources as a strategy to get the
traffic
so apple events very very famous and a
lot of eyeballs are looking for
it so my plan was to create mockups
and based on rumors before they got
released
and tried to be the first one to release
oh smart strategy
yeah so i put my name in here vlog
graphic was also my name
um valgroff was graphic and also sounded
like a company
like more authority and that was what i
led with and i put my name in the status
bar and everywhere so i could see if
people actually used it
and i actually got a lot of traction i
got a lot of people that follow these
and thousands of downloads and views and
super exciting good way for people to
get my name out there and then i started
go into
redesigns so this is what i'm doing
today but back then i used
use dribble linkedin facebook and so
many more
hey can i ask you a quick question yeah
those mock-ups that you made
did you make those in ai or photoshop or
how did you build those things
i did in photoshop so i think most of
the times i took a previous model
and then i remodel it based on that i
see yeah it's a super smart strategy and
i know you're still relatively young but
at what age are you doing this
so this i believe i was
maybe 19 20. wow hey john i don't know
what you were doing at 19 but i was
definitely not making money 21. that's
what i'm trying
still young though still very young okay
keep going i'm sorry i missed this time
it was very fun
very exciting uh so i moved into
redesigning the products i used
uh to express my ideas i found there was
lacking
in the way they displayed the content
the way
i felt engaging with different functions
dribble for example i had one feature
set
of giving feedback voting a or b like do
you like this
version or not we still don't have that
today
and they also gonna shut down their app
for some reason
so i think there's some improvements
level in in things we use so this is
what i
used as an inspiration to get going um
after this i moved to the capital
stockholm time to see some buildings
time to meet some people
in the capital so this was an adventure
i've been there i think
three times before so i was really close
into this village
but now i moved here and the first
adventure was to go to hyper island so
this was the beginning of my education
so before it was high school and this is
my
my only education after that really a
higher vocational
practical school where it's not really
traditional as
any other school you can imagine it's
more
we have no exams so we have instead
industry leaders coming into
school lecturing about for example
someone from fantasy could be there
and talk about how we design in san
francisco and then people take notes
and they learn and then we have modules
that we collaborate in teams
so it's very much the soft skills how
you communicate as a
as a person reflect on yourself your
actions
what it means to others and the
importance that if you want to lead
change
culture is going to be the core
beneficial factor there
so that was a good time yeah there's a
there's a comment here in the chat it's
like i really like his personality i'm
gonna go check out his website
oh nice yeah it's good i'm nice
sometimes
you you seem pretty nice guy yeah you
got an interesting background too
yeah very nice been it's been it's been
a journey i'm trying to stay humble as
well
and it's just it's hard to remember
where you come from sometimes because
you get into the work
and it's very very uh intense
i would say i mean it's been four years
for me now in san francisco
and um yeah it's been intense but very
very
uh beneficial so after hyper
i decided i want to land a job in san
francisco for some reason
i think my uh my motivation was it's
hard to get it
to get there it's the biggest
opportunity when it comes to
tech jobs facebook google apple all
these
campuses what if i could be there and
see how it looks like
in real life and so my journey began
to try to apply for a job and being
swedish
and applying for an american job is not
the easiest thing
it's a lot of culture clashes it's uh we
have a
we are thinking sweden called the law of
jante and that is basically that you are
not
it's a social law you're not anything
else than anyone else
you are equal to your people and you are
not allowed to brag
like the bragging is the worst thing you
can do we've still got some swedish
people bagging
but like outwards you don't want to
become the braggy
person so in this case i used um you
know
cover letters updating my websites
tracking
every single link that i sent out trying
to analyze when they went in i literally
went in every 30 minutes to see if the
number changed
going into hotjar a tool where you can
analyze your users online
seeing where they click what they drop
off how i can improve the sites
here actually funny i have fantasy notes
since i applied
and then this is i think one of two
years before i
went to fantasy uh where i did all the
notes
where they come from how big they are
and all the action items
so very stalky this is how i found my
girlfriend as well here in san francisco
you got to be dedicated we'll talk about
that later it's the second episode yeah
that's another talk yeah i need some
help on that front
yeah it's a little creepy but i think
yeah yeah it's pretty good
if it works it works you can't argue the
results exactly um
so then i so in the end of this i really
didn't get that traction that i wanted
it's
hard i called up and said hey my name is
pontus i want to work for you and
they're like oh upon the tune that was
super fast and i was too slow
and i didn't get to the point you know
and then i said
screw it i'm just gonna fly over there
and see if they answer me if i
show up on their doorstep wow and that's
what i did this is my second flight ever
i went to like
spain and denmark when i was younger but
that's it
and i don't remember this week to be
honest i went there
every week and went into san francisco
and just showed up and said hey
here i am you didn't respond to my email
so
i flew here and then i had my resume i
think it was
13 pages because you don't fly across
the world to
show one pager i had my work i had
everything
okay and that was very exciting yeah
yeah yeah we don't necessarily endorse
or recommend this strategy it has worked
for
pontus but uh i i'm gonna reserve
judgment for the rest of you guys
do not show up at a place to take a
flight across the world with a 13-page
resume
i'm just saying that is a big that's a
fun adventure why wouldn't you recommend
that
because you might get your heart broken
i'm just saying oh yeah i got that too
yeah
okay yeah and many people didn't know
what to to respond to be honest and i
don't blame them
uh i think it was just amazing that i
had that dedication to go there
and that was my last try i didn't want
to give up so
i got there eventually but then it was
the final challenge and i think this is
the
the hardest part and still is it's just
being a foreign going to a different
country
applying for visas and if anyone have
any sort of
relation to this process they want to go
abroad
hit me up and now i'm happy to help you
out because this is a very very
stressful situation
and yeah it could definitely kill your
passion but i'm happy i had that passion
to stay persistent
and just go through these paperworks and
legal
it's just a lot of work um but yeah it
will be worth it in the end
and i'm here for you as well if you do
the same
then after this i'm finally made the
move across the big pond
a big big move uh still missing my
family to not be close to them
but my goal now was to establish myself
in san francisco
so i started off at punch cuts fighting
for the humans at punch cuts
driven by very delicate research and
methods
to make sure that everything works in
real life a really
great team there i encourage you to
check them out as well
and they kicked off my career in san
francisco and i'm very thankful for it
so i have a question for you yeah so
your intent on working at fantasy
didn't totally work out but you found
something that did work out
and then you had to deal with the visa
issues in order for you to stay in the
country and work right
yeah i mean that's very challenging i
know all about that from an employer
point of view so
it's amazing that you got in and this
worked out this looks really like
fancy like what you're showing here and
i know that you're going to talk a
little bit about after effects a little
bit but
are you taking the screen recordings and
then animating all these things on or
this is how those sites actually look
when when you visit them
yeah so this is actually the intro page
of punch cuts uh so this is the team
i didn't work on these products this is
recent but yeah they do some amazing
work over there and
really amazing research and backed by uh
very good people
perfect yeah and then
yeah go on no zana thanks for clarifying
yeah of course
and this is also intro but also some
nitpiding with the designs uh some reels
that we have
fantasy going beyond conventions uh
trying to challenge at all times what
else is out there
to be done so this is where i'm at
currently
we have offices in san francisco new
york london and then a global team
across europe australia asia so
we always think what if and
there to not settle for the for the
ordinary and being very different
and this is very very exciting yeah
and and then i have my own stuff on the
side i've always been the one that you
saw in the beginning
on the side exploring ideas
exploring ideas different techniques
sharing
recently i kicked off my youtube channel
again to share more tutorials section
here
with guides follow step by step how to
animate things
uh trying to be straight to the point as
well still learning
uh but really exciting and this live
stream is used at top of the iceberg
when it comes to just
yeah sharing something and be straight
to the point and give valuable
content for people because i've myself
found it was hard to find someone that
can tell me
how to animate this smooth interaction
on mobile product design
it's hard it's a lot of motion graphics
and
branding and design but not really ui
animation
right so i think that's the gap i was
going for here
yeah so it's a lot of work and a lot of
passion that goes into these uh
on the side here and yeah this is the
enter slide of my actual uh content
today and
it's about how to make a product
memorable today we are bloated with a
lot of digital experiences
and we spend a lot of time on them i did
see the
social dilemma did you see that
documentary not yet everybody's been
talking about it
but yeah it's buzzing it's a very
important topic when it comes to ethical
design
and the intention we have behind the
things we do
and i take it very seriously and this is
just uh
we inevitable we will have screens for
some time in our life
until we have augmented reality until we
can zone out and be with nature instead
but until then let's try to make
delightful experiences
make them nicer to look at use and also
the needs that you need to fulfill when
you use them
so this is the agenda for today
current reality just a quick recap of
how it looks like today in product
designs and principles
then i'm going to go into some
opportunities some mindset of where
we see some gaps and what you can
improve then i'm going to go through a
master class case study i have a talk
like this on my youtube
default one but here i'm going to go
into some just details of it and
also ask any questions along the way
because it's going to be all live and
custom
and then number four we're going to go
away from the keynote and go into after
effects i'm going to show you
how a product is out there now that is
missing a point in some area and how we
can animate that live
uh making it a little better and
delightful and then in the end use key
takeaways
for bullet points for you to take with
you yeah and as poncho said
earlier on we want to make this as
conversational as interactive as
possible we're talking about interaction
design here so
you guys if you have questions or
comments along the way and joan and i
will be scanning them so go ahead and
start submitting them
as as we go okay so don't get crazy
right now but
i think you have a couple of fans here
from your youtube channel so there's a
person here
named wanda mamba he's like he's he or
she is saying
they're loving the youtube channel so
keep it up nice there you go
yeah who else is there i can't see the
chat
yeah don't worry don't focus on the chat
okay so just keep going i'll read them
as i see them
okay let's get going into number one
current reality
50 milliseconds that's how quick a
website or
any experience is judged so immediate
perception when you meet someone in real
life
same here you have a perception of that
person when you meet them
and it's so crucial to make that first
impact powerful
first impressions are 90 94 design
related so
power of great design is bigger than
ever and this is where we can really
shine and stick out from the competition
no matter how big the products that you
compete with
if you nail this down you will be able
to succeed without
being bigger than them and we can see
that from startups being
faster shipping products and making them
more savvy in the beginning and used to
being upfront in the innovation
so use that test here i actually
searched for premium furniture brand
which one would you go for here we have
a left one number one and number two
wow for sure number two
yeah why well the photography
um the art direction set design the
minimalist design the clean aesthetic
the other one looks super cheap these
faux
metal plate that the the logo type sits
on
the choice of typefaces the the garish
colors i can go on and on
yeah don't get you started yeah
yeah it's pretty obvious right it feels
more intentional on the right side more
editorial and premium i search for
premium and that's what i want to see
and the left one maybe not make it in
this case
uh so use some stats that we are
familiar with in user experience
57 want to recommend a business with a
poorly designed website
75 make a judgment on the credibility
of the thing itself based on the website
and that's pretty crazy
like the company itself and then 88
would not return to a bad experience and
that makes sense if you don't have a
good
time why would you try to do it again
and that's why you need to hook them in
the beginning
so here's just a few examples of this if
you go to a restaurant
you get a really bad meal or the food is
not good
would you return to a restaurant that
served you this awful food
or would you just go next door try
someone else no way
i would not return and then another one
here dating's a little different
but let's say it's really bad really
really bad like this guy's not into her
at all
would you go on a second date if you had
a bad first one
maybe not this is about humans you
should give people a second chance
and so on but principle wise maybe not
and john would probably do it for sure
yeah just kidding
over here hard times yeah hard times man
that's good you're gonna give people
chances
and the last one here this is happening
to me every time i look at on a big
movie
really i don't know what to expect when
i look at a cover i don't really get
that
yeah knowledge of what to expect from it
and i watch it and then midway is lose
interest
and would you recommend a movie that
wasn't engaging with you
and i think the answer is also no and
so this is very damaging for your
business and something that we need to
capitalize on
so then what is the opportunities with
this so
first off we should consider our user
needs or
human needs i don't like to call
ourselves as users
but our needs when we use something and
the expectations
but then let's add a pinch of delight
let's add the enthusiasm to the product
to help you feel more human more
friendly and not keep it
that data focused and transactional
we want to have a good time so let's
just do it with our phones as well
so here's just one concept that i've
been working on this is a couple of
months ago
i did the urber jump app bike booking
app
uh so i found that it was super hard to
find my bike i actually booked
bikes pretty frequently that time and i
used
i think every time i booked the bike i
couldn't find it it was
it was not there so i wanted to have
this augmented reality
that comes that way you scan through the
environment you can see it
and then you unlock it and then you're
ready to go in this case
you can do this whole experience as a
delightful experience like the augmented
reality
technology but you can also do the small
details you can see we tap the
icon it transforms to this line and it
goes up
like a little swirl and then it becomes
the shake mark and that's a very small
thing
in the bigger picture but that whole
thing can add extra delight to the whole
thing
so you don't need to do you don't need
to go crazy in this case
um it's often the small things
and about that this is the hierarchy of
the needs to fulfill before you can move
up to
larger goals so for example functional
is it solving a problem
the yelp app isn't giving you the help
to find a restaurant
yes then we can move on to rely reliable
quick response as expected
do you trust this site to give what they
say they can give you as a function
and then we go to usable the right
information at the right time
is it more intelligent do you feel like
it understands your needs
when you hover things you get more
options you can expand the map to see
more
based on your location and then we go to
the pleasurable thing and this is what
what this is all about the microcopy the
way you talk about your things
the subtle animations where you open a
hamburger bar it's smooth
i saw on your website that you have a
really really nice hamburger bar just
going down dropping down
and then i went to skillshare and it's
not as good
and i really see the difference there if
i feel the difference
and i hope yeah i mean stop blushing
there right
yeah a little nervous um
this i think if i had one wish it would
be to not be a designer and we use
products because you know i'm very
dedicated into this i work with this day
to day
and i wonder if a normal person sort of
say would
would see this but i think the fact is
then saying that
they do they don't really think about
that the animation is great
is great it's invisible so
i think it's easy to get stuck in our
minds uh yeah i think they feel it they
might not be able to pinpoint it but
they're like oh this doesn't feel so
good
exactly yeah um but then we often hear
this is what we hear maybe every time
it's not possible to build it will cost
too much
it will take too much time it's not what
others are doing so let's not do it
and we should use launch something get
out there see what's happening
but then we need to remember this is the
key moment here mic drop moment i would
say
your customers don't care about your
profit margins they don't care how much
it costs
how much you saved or how long it takes
to for you to build it they care about
great experiences
they care about fulfilling their needs
they want to feel that it's enjoyable
that you care about them so if you make
that extra effort
they will feel it and it will be worth
it and if people feel like it's
memorable
they will also have your brand in mind
and they will return and they will tell
people and ease goes on and on and on
so yeah if i ever ever build a product i
haven't
built an actual product yet
independently
but i think yeah it's easier said than
done to do this it's a lot of factors
that goes into it
but i think it's just important to have
that mindset of if we can
let's try to do it and this is what i'm
going to talk about in the masterclass
case
how we how we got it together um so yeah
as i can as i said nothing is perfect
but it doesn't need to be
because if you put in the effort and
people feel it
they are okay with some barriers and
some glitches when it comes to designing
it's a lasting feeling and that's the
most powerful thing here
yeah so that was it and then we have the
case study
before we move on any questions or uh
conversation about that
i have to pick up no because you dropped
it over here
i have to pick up the mic you have to
you drop it over here yeah
good no your your presentation style and
your your deck is super smooth man
oh my god i'm feeling it so i i think
everybody's just going along for this
very excellent ride right now so let's
keep going
okay let's do it uh yeah so fantasy
and nasty class teamed up some time ago
to deliver delight
with masterclass to reimagine their
digital ecosystem
with mobile apps tablets content
strategy
user experience visual design animation
and then finally implementation to get
to launch
i think the product was around two three
months from start to finish
and yeah a really exciting project as
you can see
very cinematic uh images and the used
recap of what masterclass is is online
classes
taught by the very best steph curry we
got
dead mouse djing we got gordon ramsay
cooking food for you
we also have one guy teaching you how to
go to space i haven't watched that one
yet
but maybe we should use the cinematic
footage here was what
caught my eye and uh is really the
difference when it comes to
like the quality so we built on this uh
later on
so just before we start anything we go
into and check out how the current
landscape looks like
so this is an overview of just a heap
full of apps when it comes to video
streaming and movies netflix hulu hbo
disney roku pluto i can go on
but this is like the set of how
generally the latest app looks like
so if you look around here we see
there's a lot of patterns so we see a
lot of movie covers
we sell a lot of flat things and i can
imagine that most of these are stills
some of them might be scrolling and
playing in the background as a header
to give some more immersiveness but most
of them feels very static
and in a carousel setting like you tap
into one
and you go out and the branding moment
here is really
the outside of it so if we go use black
and white here
it kind of feels like the similar app
across the board here there's some
differences
i'm not saying it's the same but it kind
of feels like the ui is just
the same like everybody else have ever
done it
and then they brand it with a color so i
wonder if this is a
opportunity that we can capitalize on
make it
more distinguishable and also exciting
to use
so what was expected was maybe something
like this
a header with stephen martin we have
two carousels acting and cooking and
then you scroll through them
you tap into one and you land on the
class detail on the right
or you go into a list in the center to
see everything
about a specific category so this i
believe was the
expectations when you see this brief
but our version was clear it was don't
recreate netflix
or what everyone else is doing it let's
not be one of those let's do
something different see how it flies and
hopefully we can make it work
so we did so by leading with the human
connection
you see people you see their faces you
get interested in what they are doing
so we have this master wall as we call
it a grid full of people
we scroll through and and navigating as
you can see we have a grid view and a
list view and the grid view
this one is all about the visual
exploration being curious
uh we want them to explore further than
their
initial interest areas so in this case
if you go into a list view you will
immediately start reading and you will
get into very like tactical
choosing but in this case i have no clue
what they are doing and i would say
this representation of the photos is not
the final ones
it should be more if annie labout for
example she's a very famous photographer
and she would have a camera in view you
would immediately know that she's doing
photography
i don't need to know a name i don't need
to know a class name
gordon ramsay who would have a knife or
something scary i would also know that
he's cooking
so i don't need to bloat the screen with
this type so
that's something that maybe got iterated
after we hand it off but this is just
one
version of this and then the way you
animate this
and previewing a class you start in this
full view
you tap into one card and it goes full
screen the video is playing in the
background
you get progressive more information as
you go deeper
in and then also when you are in this
mode
you can then swipe through in any
direction let me go back here a little
bit
yeah you can swipe in any direction of
the exploring and you see
what's out there and you also get the
preview loading with the
audio to learn what they are doing so
you don't need to do the hard work to
tap in and out of things
and then we're to talking less and
showing more so we we lead with this
beautiful cinematic footage
we try to keep the type to the minimal
you can have a read more
but it shouldn't be the majority of the
screen it should be more imagery
it should be more video and show what to
learn from it
and then we have the onboarding this is
very exciting because this is the actual
onboarding flow that we
uh it might be iterated on right now in
the live app because this is some time
ago
but this is the actual video that plays
when you open the app for the first time
so you know it's going to be more people
than use one
so we we get that check mark and then we
know the animation of how you navigate
the entire
app so we don't need to do that scare so
like you swipe left and right and
top so you you would tell everything by
just playing that video in the beginning
and then use the details here when it
comes to the animation so i first
started by
animating in this like a whole set of
grids
but then that felt like a jpeg they just
came at me and then when i moved around
they were
like one unit but they are separate so
it's key here to animate them in
progressively and also that bounce
because they come in with some force
uh how they are faded in and the edges
and also when you move around we also
played around with parallax like some of
them are skewing faster than others
there's a lot of explorations here that
we did and that was really exciting
are you mocking these things up in after
effects yeah so i think
i'm going to touch on that later but we
i did motion
uh and design with my team and we did
that first but it ended up being very
much in code
and beta apps because we had a killer
team over there
so that was really really beneficial to
see it live
but then here adding physical reactions
so if you have something
like my phone i just push the phone here
it will skew down right it will not be
flat so
we played on that as well uh how that
looks like and that added the depth in
the background the blur
the shadow and a lot of details there
and then also the weight so to produce
one of these classes
it takes around 6 to 12 months to
produce one so
we want to add weight to this it's a lot
of value in one of them
so on the right side you can see that
it's very heavy when you move
so it's like delayed and that's also we
played around with
it feels more heavy uh if the animation
is
done that way i see yeah
so there's a built-in resistance as you
pull and drag
yeah i'm not sure exactly how it works
in the app i believe we had different uh
tests there that we tried out um
yeah so that was exciting and then the
result is 12
and was very successful from launch
rated for its experience so 4.7 stars on
the app store
got app of the day in the us and the uk
and all of that is exciting of course
but it's all about the people here with
uh just learning like they really have
this device now when they can take
masterclass with them
on a train on a journey and learn
wherever they are and that was the whole
premise
with the with this brief and that was uh
that was the core thing that we wanted
to achieve and then also some nice
awards
uh webby winner recently for the best
education app
and then recently also the mobile ux
award at
2018. so yeah a lot of recognition
and very very happy that it went that
well
and then just invested for its value so
of course the business itself
is invested for but i want to claim that
if the experience is bad
the business is also going to be worse
so in this case it's been very
successful so we have 100 million
in this year for more fuel content and
uh yeah that's great this is
great growth ever since they started
really it's a great company
and uh very exciting to see what to take
it next
yeah there's a question here from the
internet from stay balanced
and they're asking can i get a job doing
this
design animation i think motion
design mock-up for for mobile design
absolutely yeah i thought so yeah
totally
it's so sought after to have that
animation i
that's why i got into the animation
that's like the core like final touch
on something like for example if you go
to internet
and you see everything static imagine if
there was no motion
at all and everything is blinked when
you click a button
or when you open a new page that will
not be good so there's always some
motion into it
so i think motion is the is the
superpower
of product design moving forward
so use motion design to mock up things
to see how they feel
and once you get approval or sign off on
people and then the
developers then go make it yeah so i
think
it's always that expiration phase of
course in the beginning uh i did some
wild
concepts with the team of course that
didn't really fly
too heavy too much videos
my friend peter he did uh like every
face was talking in the master wall at
the same time
but on mute and when you go into one it
started to play with sound but that was
just too heavy
and how would you determine if they are
in view so i think it's a constant
communication with the
with the partner to understand how they
build things
but just keep that in mind like
everything it's kind of possible
if you want it to be possible it's just
a claim here this is very complex it was
a lot of work for our developers
but they were they were bought into this
uh and i'm gonna go into this right now
actually
what made this possible and i think the
core thing is that
we shared the vision we had this goal
aligned even though we are a fantasy
crew coming into their office
and we wanted something maybe extreme in
the first glance
but they kind of went for it they felt
that it was something to explore and we
we approached it in a humble way where
we shared our
vision and then we try to align with
them and try to understand and share
why that would work and why it's
important to do so
so we became a part of their team so we
didn't just
got the brief went away in our office
and
talked to them again three weeks we were
there three times a week
at times working with them sitting at
their desks and just collaborating on
iteration of their iteration to find
what is feasible
what is that delightful moment where is
the limit to
when it's too complex and so on um
and yeah here's the team the lean
trusted team the made it all possible
core team from fantasy and then we have
sebastian in the end there in the bottom
i need to shout out that guy because
he's amazing when it came
to the animation he never hated me for
my animation
critique i said move this two
milliseconds
uh faster and he used it without
complaining
a little bit
yeah so yeah just a lean team so you
don't need to have
a amazing big team to make something
like this work
of course it depends on your
organization but we all have the passion
to make this
mission statement possible of making a
very generic as first glance video app
to be very unique in the market and just
hit it
and then as i said before daily
iteration with the app build so this is
live
on sebastian's desk um doing one
prototype of the onboarding so after
this is done
you then get one text saying start
exploring
anywhere and yeah it was that was
amazing just have the prototype in your
hand feeling it testing it with people
with users
and validates if what we are saying is
crazy
or if it's crazy good basically
and then of course as everything
detailed specification of
every state in the digital design in the
user experience
uh how everything in states looks like
when things come in
in view but basically we kind of skipped
like the details of this as you can see
here this is more a visual
representation of what's going on in the
background
but we kind of skipped right into the
development which was
very beneficial yeah so there we go
that is the the whole experience that we
had
with masterclass um yeah and uh
yeah great team with the work awesome
yeah i'm a master class subscriber so
i've been checking out this app
yeah nice nice yeah very nice yeah what
do you think about the app before you
heard this
talk about it um i
i feel a lot of the things that you're
saying um even before this talk
one thing that i think and i think this
is strategic that master class does this
is
it's not always easy to figure out where
i'm at like if i'm following
one instructor so i think maybe you guys
are
emphasizing exploration and discovery
versus very linear
like i've watched five of the 13 videos
with the 40 videos
it's oftentimes it's a little tricky for
me to figure out where the heck i've
been at
so yeah that is true yeah they got a lot
of
areas uh to explore yeah yeah
okay so what's next so next is actually
the design animation process
in after effects so we went through this
pretty fast i would say
um so the this section is all about uh
let's take a look on a product that's
live
today and see how we can improve it and
i'm going to drag you into
after effects hopefully you can get some
practical crafts
with you yeah and let me know if you
want to take this
semi fast or slow step by step in the
easings and the keyframes and all that
good stuff
you can freak out at times but i want to
make this
really educational so yeah so let's do
this let's
let's go a high level talk about
concepts and then every once in a while
drill deep into like this is what i'm
doing
because i think what we want to do is
get people who are interested in design
or product design to get excited about
animation without killing them on this
right
because it's a deep rabbit hole you can
go down yeah and and i i think what i
want to
do is inspire people to to investigate
after effects and think about how they
can use motion
as their secret power or superpower yep
that sounds good okay i also have just a
shout out i have these
assets i'm going to share it's on my
website if you go there
i have a section it's called it's
talking about this live stream and i
have a button calling and download the
product files it's so much beautiful
so what we'll do is in the notes below
we'll include that link so that you guys
can download the project files from
um from hunter's website
and then you can follow along yeah
follow along or
do you want the link now i think it's
going to be hard for them to follow
along live right
yeah you can give us the link right now
and drop it in the chat
and then jonah will pick it up and and
include in the notes as soon as this
episode completes okay let me just copy
paste there
yeah are you putting in the chat right
now i could do jonah
okay well johnny can find on my website
yeah i'm looking for it right now
okay cool yeah
all right let's uh let's get going so
let's take a look at this thing so this
is a company it's a multi like 100
million sub
100 million dollars valued company a
leading game
development product they state the
world's most advanced
simulation racing game with the peoria
of racing action
fun so let's dig into these words most
advanced
pure joy and fun let's see if this feels
like this when we look at it
so this is a racing game it feels very
actionable it feels like you're in
in the environment the lighting the
effects from the exhaust pipe
i can imagine the audio here is also on
spot the different view angles
different perspective when you look
backwards and so on so it feels great
i actually can relate to these words but
then you go on the website
and i wonder if we feel the same do we
feel like this is the most advanced
way of portraying this most advanced
game
and i i would say that there's some
things that sticks out i think
in the beginning it's a lot of things
going on at the same time
it's a lot of gradient colors some very
dramatic
movements and also some flying cars
without shadows
and without actual wheels spinning so as
you can see in the bottom
a car doesn't really move like this in
real life right it glides in like an
ice so if it wasn't an ice background i
would maybe buy it
but in this case i it feels kind of off
uh that's
that's my opinion and this is the piece
in the end
where we're gonna go and see how you can
animate in this car
in a realistic fashion and do this
without any 3d assets and just use
real world references really
so let's deliver the light to this so
this is also a reference to another
project i've been working on for
a year on the side just exploring how
formula one
can take their experience to the next
level so we're going to recreate this
specific piece of how you can tap into a
formula one car
and it will roll into view and get the
title and present for you
so this is no 3d required
just flat assets and real world
principles
so very exciting and this is something
i've been i think for a year
trying to like do these immersive
experiences but do it with the minimal
efforts
possible so it's very good for anyone
that doesn't do
3d i'm not very much into 3d yet
so i think it's just a powerful way to
elevate something
in an easy way
so yeah let's dig into it in this case i
have sketch file
and i have after effects sweet
so i'm going to stop sharing i'm going
to go with that
any comments in the chat chris
um nothing that i need to bring up just
yet
and we dropped the the download links in
the chat as well
so if you want to go check that out to
follow along great
there's one one question here from andy
who's asking what is the tool
with timing of animation and master
class and how do you deliver timings to
developers for such
type of projects good questions so
as i said before we didn't really get
into these timings uh
so often case we deliver uh mp4s
just videos references so i think that i
mean that's hard to use reference a
video and see how everything moves
so we had some shorts when it came to
milliseconds and when things came in and
out of you
but this sebastian guy and the team from
masterclass really went
right they understand the premise of the
timings they understand the premise of
how things would flow in a sequential
order so i think that was beneficial to
not do that like nitty-gritty
documentation
um so yeah we didn't really get into
those tools
yeah okay yep
all right i think people are generally
enjoying the live stream thus far
they've learned a lot of different
things and are getting excited about
animation
and i think you've already done that job
so now we get to go in the deeper dive
there was one question that was
sort of somewhat unrelated but i'm gonna
ask it
they're saying like you're you're you're
so smooth at speaking
is this your natural style are you
working with notes or
how are you able to deliver such a
smooth presentation
good question like i mean
tell us all your secrets preparation i
mean i've been
pumped up for this ever since we started
talking a few weeks ago
yeah i mean it's a lot of passion i'm
just going for it
really yeah as i said to jonah before
and you i have notes
in each slide but i didn't really look
at it i just went for it and i have
like all these things that i want to say
i believe like yes i did a talk in tel
aviv about the mass class as well
and that was my first talk on a big big
stage and
frightening very frightening but i think
what saved me was the
true passion as you maybe see here with
the master class with the moving with
the cards
a lot of stuff there was just a lot of
good memories a lot of good moments
where we did this
and it fell to my heart and yeah nose
would just be
generic for me so i i think if you're
passionate for it
you will just fall into your natural
habitat when it comes to talking but
that's something i wish i always improve
on to be better
also my english as a second language um
but yeah i'm happy to hear that yeah
yeah
very good very impressive man thank you
okay let me see if i can share this
properly okay
so now you should see a sketch file
yep and i'm gonna do
okay there we go okay so this is the
overview of the
team browsing section in this app so
the premise here is essentially to
browse the teams of formula one
and trying to give more focus to the
teams as well so let me just go into
here and say
see the different iterations that i made
in the beginning so this is like a recap
this is a project that we've gone on for
a while uh but the premise is definitely
here
the way i work so the first one is a
table view let's zoom in here
there we go uh yeah so this is a table
view it's very detailed data
you see the position the team name
points
last race there's a lot of heavy data
going on here
and this is a view that could work for
like a results page
maybe not the team page because this
feels very driven to you want to find
everything about them
and very much up front so i tried to do
one iteration here
to do a grid view a two-up it's more
visual
it's more it's less common less
information it's more about the drivers
carlos and lando in mclaren and you see
two
in a view instead of four so we're
losing some content but these are still
peaking in the back
and the bottom here and then you scroll
through here and it's also
10 teams so it's not really that much
content to get in here
so one concern is that you have to
scroll a lot to see all the teams
but in this case you you have 10 teams
and you know what order they come in
often and also you would have different
views depending on your
objective and then if we move on
to the last one which is the one we're
going to focus on
and here i brought up the cars even
bigger i want to see the details of
these colors
of the different branding they have on
the cars where the brand
coming from so great britain in this
case what points they have and what
order
so in this case we see one and a half
card in view
and in the beginning we had eight so in
this case i think it's fine because in
this case you want to focus on the teams
and and not the data and the data here
you can disclose in the actual detail
page when you
tap on it so before i go into animation
i
often try to identify how i want this to
move so
let me go here to animation flow
and this is also my process any process
is yours
c was working for you but this is
something that i found is very
beneficial especially if you get into
this complicated after effects program
or principle or any program for that
matter if you are planning ahead
it will often help you so in this case
you start
in number one here with the team we make
one scroll
upwards and see the mclaren in view
we want to tap that one and we want
everything else to disappear
and clean the screen and then you see
the cards here in the bottom some data
and details about the team
we want that to be out of view but then
one that once the car is landing
we want that to come up from the bottom
with the title
and then the brand logo so that's the
entire flow here
so this is like you're using sketch as
a storyboarding tool yeah pretty much
right this is mapping out the key
moments and then then you can go figure
out the animation
i want to take this opportunity to to
welcome people who maybe
have or may have joined us a little late
today we're talking to
pontus valgraff he's originally from
sweden in a small town but now he's
residing in san francisco
you guys go check out uh his social
accounts at
wellgraph or valgraff and
also visit his site belgraf.com
all right cool yes that was the flow
and then i tried to distinguish these
assets in the way i want to export these
into after effects
and animate them so there's tools and
plugins where you can use automate you
can just select all these
click a button and get them in there but
i've been finding that it's very
robotic sometimes it doesn't really
understand like just as i'm talking to
delightful moments
a computer doesn't really know my
intention they don't know that i want to
have
all this as a unit for example this flag
i can imagine that it's going to export
all of these different shapes
in one layer and that's not going to be
beneficial for me so in this case it's
small things but it's trying to lay out
everything that i need so in this case
i'm just demonstrating how i
like do the naming convention i try to
do image and then what it is
uh sequential orders like zero one zero
two
um and i use different assets here so
i'm gonna try to export these
what we need and then we're going to
move into after picks
i see so you're determining which groups
you want to
remain intact and which things you need
as separate assets because you want to
animate those separately
exactly yeah so in this case for example
we can start
here uh the teams so we don't want to
animate in everything we could do some
you know when you animate the end that
everything comes in like each car comes
in
uh but i think it's gonna be too much
going on at the same time and we also
will kill that
killer moment when you tap the car and
then you get that for the first time
so in this case i think we're going to
export this whole asset
with everything but the car because we
want this to use fade in
white right so you you don't need to
complicate it in this case so let's just
go into export
and and then go into
live demo and this is the assets you're
gonna get
if you download it from the link and
let's do another
folder let's do it
live animation and then also the folder
structure is also something you can do
in any way you want
but for inspiration this is how i
usually set it up so i do one folder
that is called assets
and then i try to stick in and add
everything that i use in this folder so
you don't have things on your desktop
which is easy to do
or downloads folder and then once you
move the project
you might get conflicts when you move
your projects around
and then inside this uh ads folder i do
one called image
i can do one that's called video 3d or
any other sort of
assets well in this case i think we're
going to start with image only
and then we're going to save that one
and then we're going to move forward
and we're going to see this team content
piece
it's going to be a png and we're going
to export that as well
and then we're gonna do the text so i um
outline this one so you don't need the
type styles hopefully uh yeah just hit
me up if it's conflicting with the font
but
otherwise i think you can find the
formula one font but this one is just
pre-made with the shadow i don't need to
do that in after effects and i also know
what i want to do
so it'll save that one as well and then
we have the car itself
so in this case it's just a photo and i
did some work in the background
when it's transparent so let's just do
this
uh so i cut it off a little bit there's
some some lazy masking there going on
but it doesn't really matter because i
i'll have it on white background and
also this is a bust speed this is about
use getting it out there
get people excited about this new
solution and then
later of course you would iterate on the
way you animate this to
make it feasible so let's export this
car
and then one thing here how i will
construct the wheels
so i said no 3d so that's true we will
lose some perspective
when it's moving from left to right the
camera should have some different angles
so we're going to loosen that detail but
it will still hopefully be
somewhat real so in this case we're
going to move the wheel
and put it on the mask the wheel cover
and so i'm doing this live here this is
what i'm going to do in after effects
and then we put it on the wheel itself
so if i didn't have that cover in the
background and it spinned
we would see the left of the of the
wheel i could also
photoshop out the wheel itself uh but
that's the way i'm gonna
build it up later
and then i place another copy on the
front wheel so let's
export the wheel cover and the wheel rim
and we should be
good to go
okay then i'm gonna go and open after
effects
okay so just an overview i don't know
how many is working
in after effects at the moment but you
just a quick overview of the
of the software again it's very
intimidating i have a tutorial about
this as well how you can
customize your view and get a lot of
clutter out your way
but just uh use that short interest that
you have your projects area here on the
left side
you can do your layer structure as i did
in my finder
so i'm going to go ahead and do that
right here in the center you have the
composition itself whatever you are
working in
that's where it's going to appear you
can also of course add in more views if
you have
different angles on things and different
compositions so on
and then i also like to do one folder
for compositions
and then i'm ready to drag in all the
assets
so i must find a window and then i drag
it in you can also go into file and
import
so there i think we have it
and then we're going to create a
composition for this and just in the
bottom we have the timeline
where all the layers is going to appear
all the keyframes and
everything like that
okay so let's start doing one
composition new composition and then i
have some presets when it comes to the
dimensions so i have one
called iphone x 2x i'm going to click on
that one
and now it's standing up so we're going
to flip that to a 16
24 times 750
and we do it in 60 frames per second
it's often what i do when it comes to
negative experiences
and we can do like 30 seconds or
something for now and we can also name
this to
let's do main uh or something similar
for you to
understand uh then i
have different layouts for different
views so i have this one is called
desktop
you just have a different view depending
on your dimension of your compositions
that's very
beneficial so you just if we do another
one
uh iphone x a standing one you would
have this one so i have i made this
workspace for
suiting you to the right side here
instead in this case you can really get
that timeline up here
right oops i really messed it up here
pontus i have a question are you working
on
a laptop or a desktop i have a macbook
macbook pro okay do you um
can you sometimes zoom in on your what
you're doing because it's
sometimes like my my vision's not that
good so that's what i always tell jonah
so like sometimes when you're doing like
some fine adjustments so just
snap zoom into that okay yeah i don't
know how i can zoom into the timeline i
can zoom into the footage for sure
okay i'll find i'll find out how to do
it while yeah yeah yeah
okay i've noticed that too with the
resolution
um yeah that was just demonstration with
the workflow here
um but let's zoom in we have the view
here
and before we get going here it's hard
for us to understand where everything is
going to land here so let's go back to
sketch or your design program
and go up into our animation flow and we
want to export this screen
to see as a reference where we can place
them so let's do
2x
and then we can do reference
and zero one and then we also
might wanna have the zero four here to
see where the car is gonna land where
the type is gonna go
reference four okay
so then we go back and we drag those two
in as well
and we start with the first one so we
drag down here into view
and we can start to put in everything
that we need into this view
so image teams this is the one and now
realize it's not in the right
resolution so i go back
and i choose 2x
and replace that one just making sure
that these also have 2x
and they don't
okay
now according to a little google search
it says that anything with a trackpad
like a
macbook pro if you double tap with two
fingers it'll zoom in for you
try it two finger two finger tap no
you may have to go to your preferences
to uh go to your trackpad setting
and then there should be a control for
zooming
right smart zoom oh double tap okay i'll
double click that
yeah two fingers there you go wow and
you could just zoom in and zoom out that
way
wow okay or you can pinch zoom in and
out so that's the quick way to do it so
let's go back and see
how yeah our head will it work here
let's see no dang are you serious
we're close okay i'll keep searching you
keep starting you think i was so excited
for a second they're like wow
we're gonna be able to zoom in here yeah
okay i'll figure it out
okay uh okay so now we have the right
dimension here we're just gonna place it
in here
and then we can go into you can push t
on your keyboard to bring up the
opacity attributes and all of these have
different
attributes i can give you the keynotes
along the way here but just move this
one down
to some lower opacity just to see where
it is
and place it like there and then we're
going to
put it up and that's basically it
we're going to skip the like the header
area the frame for now
and we're going to go in and create a
new solid in the background
and right click transform fit to comp
and then i'm also holding in command
and then double clicking on this one up
here that will give you the anchor
points
in the center and this is basically
wherever you are moving it will anchor
to that point
so we want this to be in the center in
case we want to animate it or move it
so then we can name this one to vg or
background
place in the background and then we want
to change the color to the right color
now we have this one we take the pipette
and then we choose white
and then we have the first view then we
want to
add in the car itself so let's try and
first off before
we really mess this up we need to save
this we don't want to redo all this
live animation live animation
f1 landing
okay so instead of you dragging in the
car
so it's very big right now and we also
want to have the wheels
correlating to the car itself so in this
case we can pre-compass this
do a pre-composition of this car itself
and do the animation of the wheels
inside of that one
because we know that the wheels we want
them to follow the car whatever that is
going
so we're going to do another composition
just right click
new comp from selection then we go into
composition and we can name this
car i'm gonna remove the old standing
phone as well
and then we're in here and this is how
it looks like and now we can go back to
the main
and we can drag in the car composition
and then we go
s on the keyboard to scale it down and
now we're going to match the other cars
and also place it where we want it to be
okay something like that and we don't
know where mclaren is going to end up
but we have the horizontal alignment as
well here
so let's let's start by animating this
little flow here
so what i like to do is to always work
with null objects
and that's basically an empty layer that
doesn't do anything other than being an
anchor point
to other things so i use that here in
the bottom i
go layer new and null object and then
again i like to do transformer fit to
comp in that case i know that it's edge
to edge i know like where it is
and then i can name this to like
scrolling movement
something and then i want to parent
everything else on this screen to that
null
so i go and select these and then
yeah i can't zoom in hopefully you see
this by going to this
pick whip drag it into the scrolling
movement you can also go into the drop
down here
so in this case if i move the thing here
now i will see the mclaren moving
and everything and if i go separately i
will move them independently
okay the internet is so smart they are
giving us several suggestions on how to
do that so let's try one
let's go back into preferences and go
into accessibility
and then there's the zoom thing so
accessibility is that little man
and then you pick zoom and then you add
the modifier key
so i think it's the one in the middle or
you can go into advance and do
double tap or three taps and all that
kind of stuff you'll know this more than
me
so somewhere in here you should be able
to do it and i tested it so if i hold
down control and scroll up and down on
my mouse
it'll zoom into stuff okay yeah
let's try that one down right yeah let's
try that yeah and you could do it
immediately if you hold down control and
scroll
mouse there we go it should zoom in and
out yeah zooming for you
it was yeah it's zooming in right no not
for me
no no i mean on my mic my computer
are you using a mouse as well yeah i do
so if you hold on control with a mouse
wheel
you just go up and down scroll i don't
think it'll do if he's sharing his
screen but like to hit him personally oh
i see i'm i'm cropping in like on my end
uh oh you're you're zooming in for him
kind of i see
okay okay we'll just do it for you on
our hands yeah i can make sure else i
have everything in views
we don't need all the real estate here
right right so i can like
do this and you can zoom down here yeah
that sounds good yeah yeah
nice damn hacks live yes
this is how life works you can't plan
this you know you can't
yeah you just adapt sometimes i want to
but it's impossible okay okay
so let's start by animating some stuff
here and i go into i usually go in like
two three four seconds something in case
i want to add something before
so you don't need to realign stuff so
let's just go in four seconds here just
have some margin
and i go into the scrolling movement
null
i click p on the keyboard and then i
want it to
span for maybe start with a second see
how that looks like
i'm using command shift and arrows key
to move
a sequential of 10 frames each time
and then i move it down so in this case
i'll just move this like this
and want the mclaren to happen like that
and then we can see how that looks like
first off we just want to move down the
car
and place it where it should be okay
and then we can go into selecting these
curves and we can play it first and see
how that looks like
it's going to be very linear and very
basic as a animation
so kind of robotic and we want to make
it more smooth
and give some more finesse to this so we
can select these keyframes
go into the curve editor they're going
to get up here
we can go back actually and just select
these click
keyframe assists and then easy ease
that's going to add in some smoothness
in the beginning and the end it's
already
much better than before and then if you
want to tweak this even more you can go
in here
make sure you're on the speed graph in
the bottom menu here
and then let's also set a setting that
we want to see there we go
this tool is doing that it's going to
fit the curve in view otherwise it's
going to be off view
so this is the curve actually when you
play this this
is pretty it's pretty stiff still so
let's try to click this one in the
bottom
and we can do like it's kind of ease in
smooth in the beginning
and then a swallow in the end it's gonna
be a little more snappy when you scroll
man you're pretty smooth at doing the
presentation and you're also pretty
smooth in after effects i have to say
there's like zero missteps
i've been practicing for two months
well thanks for saying that i know
you're just kind of keeping it humble
but
i gotta say i used to use after effects
a lot and you know why we're doing this
demo like wait where's that menu item
yeah find anything it's like zero
missteps here everybody i hope you guys
are appreciating this
and somebody is saying this is the the
smoothest best uh demo
ever so people are enjoying it good i'm
happy to hear
yeah yeah that's the goal um time is
valuable
yeah they're telling me don't mess with
his preferences chris i'm like all right
who said that that sounds like a friend
doing that
you're so ocd yeah
okay so there we go i think it feels
pretty good but then you start
call out that you can also have plugins
in after effects to do this more
efficiently
and also i think it's good to know these
animation principles
how curves looks like and and all the
dynamic around it
but i use this tool called motion2 it's
a great plugin
but you basically can do the same thing
you can select the keyframes
and you drag a curve a slider on the
right side
basically in this case i usually like i
mean i have my own like settings like 60
40 or 60 60.
and you kind of get it after a while you
know what's happening so let's try to do
like
8080 and see how that looks like
they're really going to snap there in
the beginning nice um so
it slowly starts and it it slows down
but in the middle it's really fast right
exactly so this is like uh there is in
the beginning
and also the middle here is they i think
let's see if that works
yeah this is actually moving both of
them at the same time if you want them
to do 8080 you can just move the
center as 80. and you said it was called
motion two
motion two yeah uh it's another one
called flow
and uh yeah many more to be honest yeah
but this one has been sticking with me
for a while
so motion two and you
if you don't mess around with the graph
and the curve editor it's
it can get kind of a little tricky
sometimes you would just use a tool like
that and save yourself some time
i think so especially if you if you do
it for that purpose
no yeah okay so that's the first
motion piece and now let's go into
the car so we're gonna go into the car
composition and now we're gonna add in
the wheels
so let's start by so we want the wheels
to move
at the same speed right because the car
is just moving and
we wanted to stop so we're going to have
one wheel and we're going to use it for
both the rear
and the front so let's do the wheel
cover
to a new composition let's call it wheel
and then place it into the folder and
then i'm gonna write an expression for
this
if i'm gonna are you going to write an
expression for the wheel i'm just
curious
uh no i'm not okay okay yeah that's
something i want to get into
yeah yeah yeah it's it's a little freaky
yeah
but very powerful i wish i knew more
yeah
are you good with them i okay
in my day i could do it today i barely
even know how to open up the program
but yeah that's fine so yeah so while
while
pontus is doing this i i want to tell
you guys sometimes you can
write these little math expressions so
that it'll control the amount of
rotation
based on the x x position or x y
position so if your car moves really far
the wheels will turn really fast and if
it moves just a little bit
the wheels will turn really slowly so
that's the idea but i think he's gonna
do it manually right
yeah but that sounds like a dream too
yeah to do everything like dynamic you
know you can move a thing and then
everything
changes okay so i'll go back to sketch
now actually because i made a mistake
live
of doing the wheel cover i had the thing
above it
so it should be all black we want to
cover everything that's behind
yeah there we go so we have the black
cover and we have the wheel on top of it
so let's go back to the car composition
and then we do the wheel composition and
drag it in
and now we're going to place it above
the wheel
and as you can see it's going to
actually going to fake the rear
wheel here it's actually a different
shape in the back
by using the nordap for the simplicity's
sake for this yeah
it'll be okay yeah i think we'll survive
yeah okay so there we have two wheels so
now we can animate
uh one of them and both are gonna
reflect here
so let's start by just moving the car
and see how that looks like
without the wheel spinning let's go back
to the main composition
and then after we get into view we want
the car to move from left to right
so let's do three 30 steps to the right
like a half second and then we go into
the car
we click p position and then we do
also a second to the right i think it's
going to be take longer
and then we move this car to the center
and here we have our
second reference number four and place
it above
and now we can see uh if this matching
our vision from the
visual design so i think our car is a
little too low
i think it's fine i think we will tweak
this later
but the key point is just to have it
somewhat in the center
uh we also have this frame here
so let's see if we can
you add in the frame as well what do you
think
do it yeah let's do it
some people like to party apparently
yeah
that's kyle right
nice okay let's actually also remove
these
content pieces in the top uh for now you
just keep it clean
like a frame um and use like a
background just uh
off topic here hopefully you can see the
screen but this uh
so the whole initiative with this
formula one product was to
since you're watching on your phone and
everything is 69 likes
laying down what if the app was built
for
laying down what if there was no
standing phone what if everything was
the ratio itself so you don't need to
flip the screen
every time you go into media so the way
you go into
all these pieces and the way you see the
cars
and all the all the air so this is the
entire flow of that
team landing page so everything was
built with that
horizontal landing page so and that was
the idea with this notch of
incorporate the back button like native
like android
but have it like subtle in the area so
you don't have the ui
and on top of things so that was a
really
exciting objective with all this so
let's just skip the off topic go back
export this frame
and 2x we also could actually remove the
little gradient we had in the top for
the title
uh keep it clean okay let's export this
live frame and then we drag that in
like that and then we see that the car
is aligned
and we can tweak this later but use the
the key point is that
the we want the car to move the right
distance because later it's going to be
tricky if we change the
distance because the wheel's going to
match it so let's remove the reference
and then let's see how this looks like
and before we do that we want to fade in
everything else
faded it out to zero percent
that's going to happen so i go in an
opacity 0 to 100
and that's going to happen slightly
before the car moves
so we got one second half a second and
then
it starts to move
okay so let's see how that looks like
wow thing there you go
damn there should be a speed limit on
these cars
precision braking yeah okay so
definitely let's move this
forward let's do definitely two seconds
something
uh because it's a lot of car to move and
then also the fading
and the easings we can go in here as
well and do
so the car comes in so i wonder it
stands still and it's gonna roll in
so i think it's semi slow in the
beginning
and then it's gonna be really
smooth in the end i wonder how i did
this
let's try with this
okay so one little effect we can also
add in is
instead of just fading out we can try to
shrink the content in the background
when you tap on it
so let's go into scale
move forward a little bit and then we
want to slightly scale all the content
in the background
just to get that sense that when you tap
this thing it reacts on you
and i think the cars should move when
everything is done like
right in the edge here so let's try this
okay and i think the fading could be
faster
okay so let's just try there uh i think
the key uh advance
is the wheels and i think we got the
motion here
and let's go into the car and double
click on the composition
and then we want this to match the
realism if a car
should slide in here so it's tricky so
let's do our best and see how it looks
like
so let's go into the wheel
and we want to parent the wheel
now we can use animate the whale rim
really because it's above the cover
so let's go into sk rotation r on your
keyboard
and then click a keyframe we go forward
i think one and a half second we're just
going to time this we go back to car
we go back to the
yeah we go back to main there we go and
then we go to the first keyframe where
the car is starting to move
and then we go to wheel we will then
have that point here so we move this
keyframe this is a start point of the
rotation
and then we go back to main we see the
end point and then we'll go back
to wheel and there we have the end point
in this case
let's try to spin this
two turns maybe two laps
and also as you can see it's not perfect
when it comes to
center it's a little wibbly but that's
also not really showing
when you have all that stuff around uh
okay
but ideally it would be a perfect
straight on wheel
yes unless you start there for that to
work perfectly it has to be a perfect
circle
with the center dead in the middle of
the
the wheel well or exactly right yeah and
the shadow is also from a perspective
i feel right okay
so let's see how that looks like i think
it's gonna look funny
okay oh little burn out in the end
[Laughter]
yeah so then you have to end the
keyframe earlier right
yeah it could be earlier or the if since
we ease these
then we need to do the same easing on
the output oh okay yeah
so let's do let's just drag this back to
there we do 30 and 60. see how that
looks
okay and then we go back to the wheel
and we do the same thing so we can click
the arrow here applying 30 and applying
60.
okay and in this case it could be more
it could be too many laps it could be
too much spinning
so now he's going to zoom in and we can
see we're going to try to analyze
if the wheel is spinning before the
ground is coming
it's kind of hard when we don't have
picture
but it kind of feels right it feels
pretty good
yeah let's try to play like over and
over
matching the ease in and he's out was
really what it was
i think it's spinning also a little bit
in the beginning there it's like so
let's try to
decrease the rotation let's do one and a
half
180 oops make sure you're on the
keyframe
1 and 180 degrees
let's see how that looks like
okay
yeah what does thinking people think
they're liking that so i think you just
picked up a few new subscribers to your
youtube channel yeah thank you looking
forward to share more
okay so let's stop there and now we can
animate in all the other things in the
background so
we can drag in that mclaren text it's
going to go in the background
it's pretty convincing i have to say so
yeah
if you look just at the wheel then it
looks a little funky but
in context of the car moving there's
lots of stuff going on so
you don't have to obsess over getting
that perfect because the illusion is
complete
exactly yeah yeah uh so yeah the
mclaren text in the background we want
that to pick up after the car is
coming in so right before it ends
let's do a position
and also yo now i'm going to move it
down here so you see it
and then move it forward a little bit
and then we wanted to go from the bottom
and to the top
peaking there in the background
you can also try if 3060 is working
okay and that looks okay but we also
want to fade it in because now it's
still here in the beginning
right we want it to be smooth and
invisible
so we do opacity same thing from 0 to
100
and then also applying the curves
and then also the timeline i'm adjusting
my work area with
b and n so this is the render area or
the preview area
so you don't have to preview everything
so that's very useful
i got a comment in here from ranan or
hanan
mendonsa and he's saying i'm an
architect
zero knowledge of motion graphics here
but the presentation level technical
expertise and confidence
are so smooth that i'm totally hooked
can't wait to see the
wait to see the final result well done
well done that's awesome thank you so
much
okay so there we go we have the text and
i think in this case we want it to
really
flow in the background and smooth in the
end let's
bump this up to 90. and also
oftentimes when you do text animation
when you come in they often are
fast in the beginning and they are also
passive like
they are invisible so it's fine that
they are invisible
so in this case we can also animate it
from the bottom
let's move it down a little bit more
and also slower so now it's around the
second
okay and now i kind of feel like we
don't have room
for the mclaren logo so we want to
did i export that little logo i didn't
so let's go back again
and i actually didn't even put it here
in the assets
there we go okay let's drag it from here
so export this one
to x i'll update that working files it's
our proper for you
okay so there image and then we have the
mclaren go back
drag it in and then we want that to be
appearing
after the big text
so in this case we can do some scripting
if you want to do
i don't know it's a little freaky let's
not do it then let's yeah let's not do
it it's basically just
it's a lazy way to align like delay
things
from basically delay everything from
this object
and you can add in like a parameter of a
0.2
millisecond or something but in this
case we can just animate it
and try to match it so let's do position
let's do opacity and then move forward
just to get it out here
and then we want it to go from zero and
we want it to move
in the bottom we want this to like stack
up like one after each other
let's do 20 90 as well
and then make it slower
okay and then we want that to happen
like let's time this motion
like the duration of it but delaying
them
so we're matching this in the bottom
here
and we just push it to the right
let's see how that looks like
and we can do even more because the
mclaren big is moving
longer and that's why it's appearing
still before the other one
there we go something
okay so let's do that for now and i
actually want to move this down a little
bit
because it feels too too high up so
let's try to see
how we can do this easily because now
it's a little complex
but not too much and then we can go into
and see what we're going to move so
we're going to move the car
scrolling movement okay but if we move
the scrolling movement here
we'll actually affect the keyframes that
we have in the beginning
so i'm going to go ahead and do
i'm going to think here because this is
real life this is what's happening when
you do something and oh [ __ ] it's
too high up and you want to move it down
so i'm going to do this live because i
mean this is the most frustrating part
when you
so this is why i really want to
reference you know in the beginning we
kind of skipped that one and that's
what's happening right now
that we are in some trouble so let's go
back
okay we want this to move but we want it
to be further down
so yes we can just go into this keyframe
and then move it down a little bit
like this
but then the mclaren logo and the text
is then
too high up because we move down so in
this case we can use to click these two
we have it here let's put the nav in the
top
we have these two and then we can go
into here on the null object
i can add in motion two and then add
another one used for now
where we can move these two together and
i actually missed one
there we go there we have them and now
so now we can move these two together
and we're just going to move down a
little bit
and then we can delete this one and then
that should be it
okay so that's a majority of it and now
we have then the content that goes
under it so we go into the left bar
we have team content and again it's one
x instead of two
so we go back to sketch
and we go into export settings export
the right size
i like how you're bouncing back between
sketch and
after effects so this is really a
tutorial on how to make your web
mobile design more interesting by
integrating
it with some motion design because there
are a lot of people who teach after
effects stuff
and i don't know how many people bounce
back and forth so that's i think that's
really cool to see
exactly yeah i felt the same when i when
i started out and i was
trying to learn how to animate these
buttons and
like motion graphic is so wide so broad
with a lot of stuff but no one's really
uh yeah solving the issue when learning
these kind of things
uh so yeah that's exciting if that's
fulfilling the need so i'm dragging in
the team content here
i'm just gonna place it in the edge
and then i want to animate this up when
everything else is done
so progressive load is very important if
we would animate this
all at once a car a text a logo content
that's going to be
overwhelming for the user and that's not
going to also
give that moment of the car coming into
you
it's almost like a cliffhanger
and then move forward like half a second
or something
and we start from the bottom
and i think we can go with 30 60
again
okay and that can also be a little bit
before
yeah so that is just a lot of tweaking a
lot of previewing
i think if my family would see me doing
this they were like why are you
repeating this
thing 400 times
[Laughter]
it's making little tweaks getting the
timing right yeah that's what it takes
it does yeah
okay yeah it's looking really good yeah
yeah and then we can add in details on
this and if we want to continue i'm
super happy to do so if we want to
um i'm jonah i i think i'm i'm getting
um
towards the end of my live stream uh
endurance here
yeah an hour and a half yeah we're at an
hour and a half so i think you timed it
really well yeah that's good yeah yeah i
have an idea i have an idea
since this is kind of like the first
time we're really diving deep into
uh web design ux ui product design and
also integrating with animation
i'd love to like get this out into the
world and see what our fans think of
and and perhaps invite you back and
maybe we can go to that next level where
we go even deeper and add
some of those really nice touches that
uh that separate
normal animation from like that next
level what do you think
that sounds great i would love to do
that there's a lot of stuff to cram in
so totally understandable yeah yeah yeah
so but i think you did an excellent job
of explaining it and going step by step
and bouncing back and forth it's a live
demo
and so you saw a few things that i loved
how
pontus was just kind of correcting it on
the fly
let's let's do this let's use uh the
last few minutes here to answer any
questions because i said we would be
reading questions and so i think people
have been very patient
and not overwhelming with questions
during the live so that i would
interrupt you
so here's one question from excellence
at again
he's asking how long did it take you to
complete the animation for the whole
project
um so i think i mean i've been
recreating this now
for uh for this demo and before
so i think it depends on your level of
course
but i think it took me around
30 minutes if i had all the assets
yeah but then of course all the design
iterations and all the things
and it's hard to say because i've been
working on this for like a year just
passionately on the side right as you
can see we covered a lot here
just even though we went in step and
stuff so right
okay maybe a different question is then
in terms of the master class
animations that you did to show off the
user interface
how long did you have to work on that so
we worked in
um yeah daily iterations really
so it could be by the hour we returned a
new render with a different easing
uh difference and yeah just like weekly
as checking in with different iterations
on the experience
yeah so you can turn around pretty fast
when you get into
animations and stuff and yeah
so i think the thing that most people
tend to skip
because it's kind of boring is project
management
naming architecture and figuring that
stuff out and it seems like you're a
very super hyper organized person
because if you start doing this and
you're like two or three weeks into a
project
and your project's a mess and they ask
for a simple
change or tweak because something isn't
working that's when it becomes a mess
and i can tell like you're super
organized in the way you you structured
your project in the way that you think
which allows you to do many iterations
really quickly yeah
yeah that's true and that happens too
it's
uh i'm trying to like iterate that's it
my passion of mine is also to
find techniques and after effects to be
more smart about
if there will be an iteration what
happens so for example one thing we did
here
is that we added in four seconds of
nothing in the beginning
because maybe someone says ah we want to
have the
formula one logo landing page in the
beginning we want to
see this flow from this beginning and so
on so then we have four seconds here
that hopefully can cover that need
and if it's more than four seconds yeah
too bad you just need to
to do it over again uh you can move this
in this case it's
a fairly simple thing you can move these
layers on the left
and you have now eight seconds but it
depends on your
complexity but imagine if you have
pre-compositions above
each other you have to time everything
uh but i would say
yeah i mean i kind of don't know
everything as
well in after effects i'm still learning
a lot like even in this live stream
uh how things are correlating where you
should know
things uh and i think just uh yeah let's
work together to find the techniques
together because
everyone does it in different ways so
jody did you find a question that you
wanted to spotlight
um
i guess there was this one i feel
overwhelmed with after effects
layout and imagine managing the comps
would you suggest
me a beginner to start learning
animation
okay so it depends
what you're doing if you're doing motion
graphics or if you're doing
product ui design have to do here but i
think in general the principle is
maybe set like if you are organized
maybe it will be more
organized and you will know where things
are and just
find a way for you to find your way like
don't copy what i did here just because
i told you
uh so you can find a different way with
the layer structure and the way you
name things but i think taking it easy
in the beginning to find
your way of going trying to find the
basics
of what animation works the curves for
example that i showed
um it's the small things really you
don't need to animate this car you can
also be
just the way you tap on the button like
it bounces that's just a
one layer thing um so i think you can be
as complex as you want to but i think
start
small and then when you're comfortable
move upwards
but hopefully there's resources to help
you in the journey
yeah well on that note about resources
uh felix orwari
is asking where can self-taught
designers learn how to make such
intricate animations i am one who hasn't
been able to dive
deep into motion design as i don't know
where to start so
i assume that you're mostly self-taught
right yeah
yeah i do i never went to college
so i kind of miss that journey sometimes
i feel like i want to have that
physical stamp that i i'm actually know
what i'm doing
and but there's multiple ways to land a
job or being
good in something and yeah i've been
really just
digging into youtube tutorials
throughout my life and
today is amazing because you have
skillshare you have all these courses
and it was not that way when i started
uh which is great but it's also still
hard
to get there because it's still a lot of
stuff to take in
yeah but i would say yeah the resources
now i'm doing my best on my channel
to do so as well because i i found that
gap
i didn't really get the help as i wanted
so yeah so great so in summary there if
you
are a self-taught person and you want to
learn more about animation there are a
lot of free resources that you can use
uh first one i want to point you to is
go to
pontius's website or go to his youtube
channel and start digging into their
his content and there are other
tutorials that you can find and there's
paid ones behind
skillshare which you can watch or you
can go check out uh
my friend um joey corman with his
animation boot camp
over at the school of motion and that's
it's relatively expensive but compared
to free
but those are some resources but if
you're really interested in this and
you're passionate about it
nobody can stop you from learning and
you just got to get in there and try so
once again i'm going to tell you guys go
ahead and download the links in the
notes below in case you're joining us
after the live
and and pontius has shared assets with
you that you can then download and
follow along
and it's probably going to make this a
lot more sticky
if you actually participate not just
watch it's one thing to watch and
actually
get in there and set the keyframes and
start to adjust things right
yeah excellent okay all right well i
guess it's the end of our live stream
and and uh on behalf of i got a few
ending slides you do okay i have my
ending on your ending slide so go ahead
and do your ending slides first okay
let's see if they match
all right go ahead okay let's see so i
want to just give you
three key takeaways because this is a
lot of stuff that we talked about just
make it actionable and let's see i share
my screen again
okay give john a second there yeah okay
three key takeaways from all this i'm
not singing it yet wait he's not saying
okay
hold on okay are you sharing are you
sharing the
presentation let's see
stand by everybody stay by there we go
yep there
yep okay yeah okay there we go three key
takeaways from all this
first one is share your mind with the
world on filters as you said in the
beginning
don't mind what everyone says doing
start by your mind
your vision your view and share it
and be don't be afraid of doing that and
taking consideration that it might
change by just leading by that passion
without new thinking you will go a long
way with you
and your team even though you might have
a
traditional team that is rather slowly
when it comes to innovation or they
don't feel the value is there
showing this kind of car moving in and
you see them in
physical reality it will spark some
emotions
for them and maybe they will buy into it
hopefully
number two is to take inspiration from
our physical environments
see as i said before just how things
work in the real life
if you would have an app about flowers
you want to come to the app and when you
scroll through a thing you want to see a
leave
moving when you scroll through the feed
you want to see an apple
falling and as an error message maybe
like there's no content for you maybe an
apple is falling down from above
and just bouncing off the canvas so it's
very powerful because we are humans and
you make it
human in digital is the biggest
challenge that we have
and the last one is to like this dog
provide long lasting feeling of delight
just
if you're happy it's gonna be a happy
moment and
probably your business is also going to
be very happy
and it's about the people and then let's
stop focus on the money
let's do something for each other and do
something that feels great
and that's the end well done well done
so
some applause here yeah hey if we had a
studio audience which we don't
you'd hear a lot of people cheering okay
so i think this is it just we're gonna
wrap this up
so jonah on behalf of jonah myself and
everybody that's watching
pontus i really appreciate you doing
this it looks like you
spent a lot of time preparing for this
moment i appreciate that i just
can't tell you how much when people show
up ready to teach
and share what they know it means a lot
to me and our community
so if you guys are tuning in for
whatever reason at this very last minute
here
who did we just have on the show its
name is his name is pontus
valgraff and he is originally from
sweden now residing in san francisco
follow him on social media at belgraf
that's will graph for everybody in
america willgraph.com
go check them out thank you very much
everybody for for sticking around to the
very bitter end here
and being a part of the 1 billion
mission jonah get the music ready
because i want to remind everybody
not not forget to like and comment
subscribe and hit the bell for
notifications
that's it for me until next time take
care everybody bye